well I'm Gabriel García Bernal and well
these are my 10 essential things
[Music]
so I thought that something that really
worries me a lot when not when I don't
travel I don't have it's not with me this one no I do
n't have them well this scope are the
tennis shoes to go running  which is the
way in which I know the places
where I work
the places I visit for me it is an
escape like this this phenomenal one that
connects me with the place with the place
with myself and that somehow
keeps me a little sane too And these  These
are the shoes that I use, these are
the ones that I generally use now,
this brand also because they suit me
quite well, they are quite thin and
very, very light and I don't get hurt.
It's a great moment as well as
coexistence of tranquility in some
way in a  very good way to
wake up too and I don't seem to get to
that point that sometimes with coffee it happens
that I seem to get half
broken during the day, but with
mate I kind of stay
calm and it doesn't make me so  It doesn't hit me so
hard and that's why I really like the mate that
this is, the herb that is like more Smokey
I love that one well This is my
jump rope the jump rope that
since I started training boxing
several years ago about 15 years ago  years or
so I started to get into the habit And the
truth is that this is the way in
which I warm up when before
entering a scene on the set I
usually get it And suddenly I go to
a little corner over there and  taca taca
I start to jump a little nothing three
minutes four minutes but I feel that
everything begins to flow and that and that I begin
to concentrate I also begin to
get a good rhythm and apart from that I am
exercising apart from that you
are doing me good too but but
Like there is a great way to
warm up, the truth is that coffee is
like something that is very good for me. When I
wake up like everyone else, but I think
that without coffee, I can't, like,
establish an organic nature of
thought, like no.  The ideas don't add up
and that's why I like it that's why it's good for me I do
n't like it very much at noon
and in the afternoon that's it but I like this one in
the morning in the morning but
definitely Having eaten something
because if not it's like it falls too
hard it won't  and it is a blow if it is a
strong donkey kick against the system
[Music]
If I had to elect a president this
would be the president and these would in
some way be the congress my
political structure is governed around the avocado And
the banana is like  somehow
without this during the day no I can't get
into any
no no I'm completely alienated from
where I am is what I need to eat a
banana and an avocado a day obviously
no it's not like that the most essential thing I
can live survive without doing it but
then  For a few days I feel that I
need it. Yes, I think that they are like an
almost genetic basis that I need
this composition of food
to fill me up during the day. It may be because
I am Mexican, well, maybe
well. These are some little notebooks that
could be any type.  of
little notebooks but I always have two ones
where I keep or where I somehow
write everything I have to
organize what I'm doing when
I take notes when let's say it's like
for the day to day work in
some way obviously I started it  to
do in a desire like this this one of
organization and I combined a lot of the
things that suddenly inspired me and I
started to write. So in this
notebook you will find everything, you will
find everything that happens during the
day and what in some way has to  to do with
communication with the cosmos
of everyday life and this is one that I always
have on hand because what I write
here is about some project
that I am in or the one that I am about to do is
always about something that
I am always preparing  It is something
around the same topic that usually
has to do with the same film.
So if I am going to direct a film
this would be the film's notebook
so what I write about the film
goes Here what I write about any
other things about  life goes here
on this iPad on this tablet is where
I read the news I read the different
newspapers that I read I love how to
be a little aware of what is
happening I feel
responsible plus I have to know I
have to understand I have to somehow
way to browse
satisfy that concern and well it is
through the iPad that I do it nowadays
but before I bought the newspaper
this is a black pen and then I have
a Blue pen Usually
now I don't have it here with me that
blue pen  What it does is that in some
way it becomes like the directions,
as in a script or as
in a dramatic text, there are the
directions, not the indications where
the characters, that is, it indicates what the
characters are doing, that's what I do in
blue in some way if it's like
adverbs in some way I use them
more in blue I don't know why but I start to
make a kind of
parentheses where blue is the ink
that I use for that type of tangents
of parentheses that that that  I start to
open and then the green pen is there.
I use it to underline in some way
certain words or certain ideas, certain things, like delicate things.
with something and that
gives me the opportunity to be able to follow something else.
Basically what I do is that I always
carry a fiction book and a
non-fiction book, not essays, and so
usually history is the essays or
sometimes philosophy too, but yes  there
and here between this a
book of poetry should fall. I just finished a
novel which was The Last Meeting
by Sandor Marai who is a
Hungarian writer and now I'm going to start this one by
Cormac McCarthy called
Passenger which is  A new book
has not been started yet and this is by
Mariana Matsukato who is a
fantastic economist and it is a book about the
economy and it says a guide to changing
capitalism. It is very interesting because I
just don't know if this is the place.
to talk about this but I think that
obviously there are many things that
we have to change in order to
have an environment and understand a little
better how we can live together in an
environment where we do not use up everything there
is and where we do not pollute and where we do
not destroy the environment.  place where we live
Well This is a cbd a tincture of cbd
in oil that the truth is that I
love it I love it I use it a lot
to relax to sleep the truth is
that I never buy it like
in stores generally what I do is that I
have  I have some friends who make them and I
always carry one with me, like a
little pot, and with a couple of drops I'm
done with it and it's starting to relax me
a lot and I use it, no, not every
day, but it's always good to have
because
at certain times I  I have to
sleep very early or I have to
really rest or I'm
completely exhausted and so I use a
little bit and with that it relaxes me quite
well it lightens my mind a little bit
and then I go into a
pretty good and quite restful sleep
too  So I highly recommend it
Well, I hope that they have been reflected
that they have been projected Well, with the
things that I presented here and obviously
the most essential things Well, they are not
material things, these are like 10
material objects that come quite
well and that transcend the thing  of
objects They are not only objects These are
bananas they are objects something much more it is
a glory